okay welcome everybody we are looking at
new functions in calculus and algebra
for version 13.1 of
language and
we are starting off with the
long-awaited fractional calculus
let's see where do we want to go here i
want to go to the guide page right
oh come on why does it do that
if you click on that other symbol it's
much
yeah okay you got it
so
do we have this
is he not an expert in these and these
kinds of things or do we not need that
i spoke to michael in uh a meeting this
week to show him everything he seemed
happy he gave a few suggestions for the
next videos
but he liked what i showed him
we can still call him but he knows about
this
so i think that the big thing is that
this it's
the derivative itself is not as useful
the differential equations
with those derivatives
allows you to model things but the
derivative itself it's not clear what
you use it for that's entertaining i
mean if i so i haven't done a fractional
derivative in
um okay so then this
so if i say x to the n
the half derivative of x to the n
oh gosh what a messy complicated thing
okay so if i say assuming
and
zero no
assumptions
oh assumptions yeah
um that should redden up i don't know
why it doesn't read in that case that's
a user assistance bug could somebody
please note that
can you please note that
got it
uh okay that's amusing
so
ha okay
all right
well please don't do that please don't
do that
surely we can have a way of doing it so
you don't have to fill this up with crud
like that okay i'll get it i can eyes
also
whatever i you know this is not the way
to do this i mean just put a table in
here for goodness sake don't do percent
slash dot why would you do it that way
sure
okay
okay so at one
what's that
what's that
what is that
it's an inactive emoji i know what it is
but why is it there
[Music]
what's it doing there
obviously everything has to check but we
should problem yeah sure
i mean it's like we don't generate
inactive results yes for integrals
or derivatives
it's a piece of hackery here
to avoid it doing this so we can't do
that
it's not it's not how we're set up i
mean you can't do that you can't just
generate that because the only way you
can decode what's going on is with a
human
yes right and that's just no good
so you know maybe one day in the future
we'll have a thing which generates
inactivated results from integrals in
whatever weird form we want without
evaluation but that's not today yes
you're motivating me to go on scrolling
through here
have we fixed this finally
making this actually
you know like how do i get that out
can i copy that
that's good
okay that's good that's an improvement
for sure
that wasn't working before
that's fine
okay
cool all right
who is caputo
so caputo d is the one that interacts
with the laplace transform and
is used for differential equations in
all the literature
so the kaputo d of a constant is zero
but not for fractionality which is
riemann league over there i'm sorry
that's the confidence zero so so if you
the derivative of a constant it should
be zero classically uh the fraction d
has got a non-zero constant derivative
so fractional d for constant is not zero
but capital d of a constant is zero
that's a starting point
and then the laplace transform does copy
paste is not working in this in this um
build sorry that's that's a
project management here okay so you're
telling me if i say this yes
that's right
well uh
but that's
you won't
yeah
of course if we did it twice
what's wrong with that i don't
understand the the i mean clearly if i
do the fractional integral minus one
that's an integral so that shouldn't be
zero
like why should this be zero i don't
understand why that should be zero
unfortunately
i'm sorry it's uh of one rate is it
i don't understand why that should be
zero are you guys talking past each
other what do you mean davendra first
when you say the fractional derivative
of a constant what order fractional
derivative are meaning yeah so
non-integer of course
but why should it be zero
i mean it should be same as d right for
an integer order for a positive integer
positive integer order so i just did one
positive integer there so let me do
another positive integer yes
yes
so i don't understand what's going on
here so the fraction we should agree
with the classical d for integer for
positive integer order that's all but it
does because that does yes so but if you
have
if you have a fractional order for your
differentiation then it should not give
you a zero
but it doesn't
that's exactly
but it doesn't give you zero so i don't
understand what's going on okay so for
positive integer you have a zero because
the derivative of a constant is zero
for a negative integer you have the
integrals that can't be zero
but they're not zero they're right there
yes
so i'm saying that if you take a
fractional order derivative of positive
order then you will not get a zero
so you take a sure but why why should
you oh i see what you're saying you said
you're saying
that the positive it could be the case
that for positive
positive derivatives even if fractional
should be zero they should be consistent
with the classical calculus expense i
don't think they should necessarily be
but i mean you can decide that but i
don't know why why
i mean i don't understand why it should
be oh yeah so if that's the way three
monthly always was developed to make it
consistent
it doesn't have to be
but that's the way it is you're right i
mean you could take any definition but i
i'm sorry hold on a second okay for
integer positive integer order the
derivative of a constant is zero yes
okay
for positive fractional order
yeah just like for negative order yes
the derivative of a constant is not zero
in the case of the riemann
case exactly exactly okay so caputo
whoever caputo is or was he was young
okay he was he was he worked in finance
in the 60s i think 60s 70s probably
and um
he is responsible for this
calculus so it's very recent compared to
riemann level but that's what is used by
the finance people by other people who
work in differential equations
fractional differential equations
so by cleverly tweaking riemann reality
here are two things one is to make the
derivative of constant zero in all cases
and also the laplace transform positive
fractional order for positive fractional
order and also he made it made it
so such a way
that the laplace transform acts
correctly on capital d it gives the
correct kind of behavior like the
standard laplace transform for a
derivative
so
so your initial value that you get are
the right ones over there basically
um
i am very confused by who michelle
caputo
or she actually was
i am truly confused by this
um
i'm just curious who i mean i just feel
like you know maybe one day we'll have a
party for all living people who have
functions in our system named after them
yeah
but this is yeah this the the entire
literature on differential equations for
fractional differential equations is
based on computation because like i said
that's what makes the linear
differential equations case work well
over there because when you do a laplace
transform of these things you get the
right kind of initial value
specifications like you do in the
classical laplace transform case that's
the real win over here
um
and so the other thing that's useful to
see there is mitta gleffler
plays the role of an exponential for
these fractional the horizontal
is actually a geophysicist it looks like
i see
i thought you're off researching caputo
i am because i want to know i like to
know okay
is it the same michelle caputo
rheology
well there's a bunch of stuff about
rheology here
okay you can you too can can see the um
the life and times of of this
oh no induced from variation due to a
prime rate
same person yeah analytical model of the
fischer equation with memory that looks
right because he was actually working in
finance
i don't know what it was actually
let's see
that looks like a guy stephen
it does look like a guy so that that's
that's correct you were right about that
um
but he has a female first name michelle
no it's just italian
okay
well
we should send a mail when when we
actually have this function implemented
um
well there we go working diffusion of
fields with fractional derivative models
okay fractional memory formalisms in
finance and economics just exactly right
all the rules actually but of course
these days used for things like
engineering
for electrical circuits it's not clear
how practical these are but there's a
wide uh literature i mean very wide
range literature in this field there's
kind of been an explosion of
publications in books i mean in articles
too but books
over the last two decades
okay
so
okay well fine
um
i'm going to order this fellow's book on
memory mathematics and economics
from 2018.
so memory refers fact that these
fractional digits have memory they go
they are integral so they go from 0 to t
so they're useful for for memory
you know building membrane systems they
kind of remember what happened at
earlier times
right
um
okay all right fine
okay so now at least we know who
caputo is
uh
all right support for fractional
differential equations so
so does diesel work with these yes yes
there are plenty of examples very nice
examples you can even try i mean you can
just take your favorite differential
yeah so i mean the example is that
notebook over there also if you want the
notebook or you can look at reference
pages which one which one here this one
yeah that's the complete report on
fractional calculus
all the three phases like the derivative
the laplace transform and the
differential equation there are plenty
of examples over there
so the harmonic oscillator for example
yes you can just take that and make it a
kaputo d and it'll work and there's lots
of them over here lots and lots of them
but you don't see elementary functions
you they look elementary in the end when
you actually you know do
the
okay so if i if i were to take for
example here
and
well let's let's do
so i want the f fractional analog of the
diffusion equation
so i would take um no not the diffusion
what i'm sorry fractional analog of an
exponential you could do yeah you could
do y prime equals minus y so so here
yeah
yeah
i do an alpha there
oh and you need to give an order because
it yeah because it it won't it's not
that i mean
alpha is too general over there so it
probably won't be good enough you might
need to give the actual order over there
even for the exponential
well the point is that the alpha is a
little too general the problem is if you
don't know what the alpha is you you
don't actually know what the you know
it's either a variable i mean so is it
going to go on forever there is it going
to happen it no it won't go on but it'll
probably take a bit of time to go to the
laplace transform that's all there you
are now if you actually plot that
uh or you make it very close to one like
you know 9900 it looked pretty much like
an exponential
what do you think it should look like
yeah now try and plot it it doesn't look
like an exponential but if you try it
actually plot it it will be clear that
so if i say d solve value here that's
better yes yes
okay you might want to give an initial
condition if you like you don't have to
okay so if i want to say plot this
yes
of the range x from zero to two
there you go okay
that looks correct
well i don't know let's try that
yeah
it's not quite straight
yeah it will not be so it of course is
going to be different but as you move
closer to one you will actually see it
because the metagrapher itself will go
towards the exponential
okay so let's just try just for fun
i understand this um so let's just take
this
and uh
that thing with y of x y of zero equals
one yeah yes
and then um
and let's go log plot
and let's go
x
do we have to do evaluate to that
probably yeah yeah put evaluating there
otherwise yeah we should we should
figure out how to make that less
necessary
okay so that's nine tenths so let's
let's now make this
99
now let's just make that n and let's
pick a table of those
four
the zippiest thing in the world
does nd solve now about this as well no
it's spreading more time to plot rather
than solve please note
the solving itself is trivial
it's a plotting that takes time
because metagluff love was exactly it's
not so quick on the on plotting
okay this is an interesting plot to show
i think yes oh thank you i'll make a
note of that
um
you can do a damp harmonic oscillator
quite nicely also with these things so
so okay hold on it's nice
well where am i putting this
this is cool really cool very nice yes
and it's remarkable how things it it
emerges well as the classical calculus
so it's not something that's strange you
know it's just very natural the
extension of classical calculus
yes
where did i put that
oh did that open in the wrong
application here i don't know where did
i put your
your um
if it's not there then it you must have
opened it in uh
wrong application oh maybe there it is
oh fractional calculus 13 1 there we go
yeah
okay
there's plenty of examples over here
it's it's so close to the classical
calculus i said yes you can solve
systems
how should i understand this thing that
is
in
is this relevant to the things that i
care about with fractional dimensional
space or is it not relevant to that is
it a different thing
if i
no this is a different thing this is not
a fractional number of variables this is
a fractional order yes
what does that mean i mean what is go
ahead
sorry you've seen that you can think of
these as being systems which uh
kind of you know um like i said they're
they're memory dependent so
the alpha or the encodes
the memory that you have so you need
um
because like your integrals go from zero
to
t
so i think that's the only
interpretation i've seen of them
and they kind of help you to save a
derivative sometimes so like the damp
harmonic oscillator has three terms
classically but the fractional damp
common oscillator only has two terms
because you can you can put the damping
term into the fractional derivative
basically
um
no but i'm just trying to understand
sorry
say that again i mean you're
go ahead
yeah i'm claiming that one the use i've
seen so far is that first of all okay so
like i said there's this notion of
memory dependence but to me it looks
like let's say you have a
classical lcr circuit with three
components in it
then what this probably has to do is to
compress it into two
uh things like you know um
l and c or something that just just two
components rather than three basically
so you kind of
why does changing the order do that i
mean the fact is from a from an inductor
to a capacitor
you're going from a you know from an
integral to a derivative or vice versa
and so this is kind of an uh something
in between an induction exactly so so
you so you can you know there's no
difference between a differential
equation and integral so you can combine
negative and positive orders all the
time there's no difference left
because every time you do a negative
order you're doing integration you do
positive auditing differentiation but
they go just
as if they would how does this get used
in finance
um
the only thing i've seen is the
diffusion equation because you can the
the time derivative in the diffusion
equation gets replaced by
um a fractional time derivative
and i don't know beyond that that's
something to explore 13 point we just
barely got to this point to be honest
over here and what i've seen so far so i
i think if i remember this correctly
there's things like um
fractional noises and things are some
somehow there's things in
i remember this vega you get fractional
directors but i don't remember why
i'd like to understand that okay anyway
but you've got the machinery for dealing
with them yes
uh
okay
that's interesting okay all right i need
to understand this better all right
anyway um
singular solutions whether to search for
so that's an option
to desolve
yeah
so it cost you extra effort to search so
singular generically there are no
singular solutions
singularity
what is the complete integral business
for example which is the generic case
right
what is it
it's related to complete integrals
actually
yeah now what i'm concerned about is
that that option
i would call it include singular
solutions because i think that the the
name singular i agree with you that's
actually a good suggestion i think that
that says actually what it does
i'll make that change no problem
okay
this is also a kind of a long requested
feature as 1990 jerry kuiper made the
first request for this well and if you
really want to understand it you can
read my bug reports from 25 years ago
don't tell me about that right before
this i was looking at tapes of mine from
the mid-1980s which include to-do lists
that i've almost finished actually there
you go
yes i'm probably one of the most
requested features for these following
from external users absolutely right
yeah and how successfully can we find i
mean
how how deep can the holes that we look
at the cracks the crevices that we look
for singular solutions in how how tiny
can the crevices be right so there are
two low order i think we are complete
exactly
so order equations
so but that the singular solutions are
i mean
is this like i mean in in in like
computational geometry there was
singular cases of things which happens
the difference is that they happen often
in computational geometry
yeah they happen rarely here right you
know with probability zero so i mean
algebraic varieties have all kinds of
weird singular pieces in them right
this is the yeah this is the
differential analog of that
which more rarely has weird pieces is
that what you're claiming yes
so if your family of curves
parameterized by something then you
might have an envelope solution envelope
of those curves and that's exactly what
a singular solution is it doesn't fit
into the family
by giving finite values the parameter
but it
still is kind of a valid limiting case
for calculus so if you pick an nth order
equation you can think of it as having
you know so generically there's what's
called a general solution with n
parameters in it right
okay and all
other solutions are specializations of
those parameters
sure right and there are ones that are
singular
that don't have those parameters that
don't depend on some of those parameters
but still solve the equations right
exactly
you know that's the same story with pdes
with complete integrals isn't it exactly
that's where it came from that's where
the idea came from actually i didn't
know how to solve it for many years
that's why i introduced complete
integral trying to understand singular
solution because
um this has been requested so long it's
not clear how to do it but now i know
how to do it exactly why is it i mean
the complete integrals thing that's a
function that's its own separate
function yes yes yes so why isn't
singular solutions it sounds separate i
mean you could have a dsor singular
solution but it would be so interesting
because complete integral covers a very
large range of first order pds i mean
almost any first order pd will have a
complete integral
okay and here they are so rare
uh and they occur in two varieties these
singular integrals singular solutions
one is these so-called envelope
solutions the other one is equivalent
solutions like you know you take
logistic equations like a dynamical
system it will have equilibrium
solutions which are again singular they
are not part of the family of solutions
they are limiting cases
okay hold on let me just understand this
sure
i see so the the caustic
yeah exactly it's like acoustic exactly
so they're very closely related to
caustics and
such things from from you know optics
basically that's where the motivation
came for clara i think who did them
first a long time ago oh
cool
wow that's pretty cool
so this is the federal equation the very
first one the cleric equation
and uh
okay so now this structure of the okay
so each one of these
that's like the solve results and that's
the list of variable substitutions and
that's the list of different of distinct
solutions
but now
and for
for
differential equations we normally only
have one thing but for differential
algebraic equations we might have more
than one thing even now is that correct
but with these single include singular
solutions
we are we have multiple
segments in the list of solutions here
right
okay
oh this is nice
um
so that's the first kind the other one
is these uh so-called
equilibrium solutions from logistic
equation
so you see over here that you have
two extreme solutions like zero and one
which are only approaching i see that
right you can only get that as limits
right so so that's the other kind so
there are two two shades of the same
thing two varieties of same thing
but together they cover everything from
mathematical from alpha bug reports
and we i've got about 20 examples which
get covered by this method
that's great and what happens when
you're at higher order it hired if
you've got some
hold on it but the problem is with high
order you have more parameters more more
constants so you might have many more
singular solutions so they're much
harder to
catalog
i think the literature says nothing i
went back all the way to forsyth from
150 years ago whatever and they don't
discuss anything beyond first order
because theory is just not well
undisputed high order
so we still have some support but it's
not a lot because there just is not a
clear approach over there
i think it's the comment i mean in
principle there is but the the the
combinatorics and the number of cases to
investigate sort of blows up basically
if i investigate you mean you get
candidates for the singular solutions
yeah yes they're right yeah but there's
all kinds of dimension possible
sub-dimensions that you have to
or and eliminations that you need to do
and they're just a lot
why can't that be done by the same type
of techniques as they used for algebraic
varieties and things
and all the various
grovinering and all that kind of stuff
so that's that's sort of what what is it
kind of done actually
um but it still blows up
you can't unwind i mean but in the i
understand but in the algebraic case
can't you unwind and triangularize and
so on
but
if you really want to investigate
some sort of singularities of algebraic
varieties you need to do like you do for
knots and surfaces
like the the software system singular
and it's
it's it's
it's very expensive to do okay fair
enough very very expensive yeah but so
we give some sensible message if you try
and do it for a 50 years right so
at the moment we're still trying to
extend to second third order with a few
examples and then we finally give up and
your message over there so that's we
just made it right now and that we got
remains to see how far we can get and
then finally we will give a message yes
that's the plan cool okay
uh cavi from our live stream comments
that fractional derivatives can be
classified as left or right depending on
which side support lies when computing
the inverse transform which are these
these i think are uh well we are not
it's probably from from the right over
here yeah so
yeah so is that is that part of the
memory issue well i think it's a
question of how you would i mean these
might be impro i guess the point they
are improper integrals so
but i think i'll clarify with the ground
and put something in
okay
well here look it looks like you've got
a formula for the integral here that's
what the thing is yes this is zero to x
yes
but he sounds good
yeah but does it matter i mean so that's
a thing to look up whether um
whether there's an alternative
definition sometimes used where it makes
sense to have just like we have limits
that can be gone from you know
left or right sided limits does this
have the same issue
yes so
we had looked at this but it didn't kind
of seem to fit in well with our first
attempt we could do it for the second
attempt i think that's all i can say
yeah but i i am aware of it yes yes
um
okay
fragile dimensional space
richard our live stream is commenting
about something to do with fractional
derivatives and fractional dimensional
space i need to understand that i don't
understand that at all i mean is it the
case that i can get okay here's a basic
question can i
get the volume of a sphere in d
dimensions
from doing the fractional direct
fractional integral of something
in other words if i if i compute
okay naive kind of computation
if i compute where did i put this um
okay so let's say
how do you compute the volume of a
sphere in volume
or a ball no i understand that i
understand how we do it but roger roger
what i'm trying to do here is
oh i see what i want to do i see what i
want to do look look if i say integrate
one
x
zero one
y zero one
z zero one
okay let's say i do two here
oh no i don't wanna do that i want you
two here i should get 8.
right i get 2 to the n
right ok so now
drum roll i want to do this i want to
say fractional d
and i want to say here
of
the heck do i want to do here
how do i do this
i'm going to get the improper integral
right so i'm going to get the improper
derivative
x to the n
right
and now what i want to say is i want to
say of that
i want to say up to
actually i want to say minus n here just
for fun
and then i want to say
oh this is cool so then i want to get
this up to
x equals two right
so i want to do slash dot
x goes to two
oops
so that should give me the
the volume
that's just weird it's off by some pious
or something
no but it's very weird no no but look
this is the volume of a cube
right
in
n-dimensional space
why is it individually sorry uh
because i just did integral the i just
did the n fold integral i see yes okay
right so it should be it should be the
analog of this integral here
yes but these are indefinite integrals
so they'll have an arbitrary constant
inside them
well yes but i just said well okay so
then let's subtract look i can subtract
x equals zero there
yes maybe that might be a good way to do
something on that shot here but
you might need to kind of normalize to
get any y but i'm just saying that we
don't have a definite integral we have
an indefinite integral so we need
so what there's something to understand
here
this has an n factorial
yes
what that reminds me of is the volume of
a simplex
if i'm not mistaken
yeah
it's like this thing isn't actually
integrating over the full this might be
you might be right this has to do with
the x goes to two here that this is only
oh you know what this is doing i know
what this is doing this is pulling one
end you understand here every dimension
i'm extending to two yes okay what i
think is happening here is you're just
pulling its nose out so to speak
and the other dimensions are kind of
you know in other words you've pulled
its most extreme point out to two
right but the other things are somehow
still
you know attached from two back to zero
to make a simplex yes
okay anyway
something like that
okay there are things to understand here
um
this is an iterated integral
right i know
right but i think that's right and i
think that that would be if i were to do
this
x goes to 2 y goes to x
z goes to y
then i'll get that
notice and notice that this
yeah is um very nice yes
i can't do the arithmetic
that's great
yeah um that's correct that's that's
consistent yeah right i still want to
understand exactly why that ends up
being a simplex but i think that's more
or less what i said
um
okay uh
okay where were we here we were looking
at
um
[Music]
implicit d
isn't that something that's been
requested for like millions of years
yes
and uh exactly right this is pretty
general it's still catching millions
equals 30 no
right
okay so the implicit derivative of this
of y with respect to x yes on that curve
is this the right way around in terms of
argument order
so the general case has a function of x
and y in the first argument
then the constraint
then the bound variable and then last is
the
the x in order the independent variables
this is a very general version of it
why is that why is it not what you're
deriving differentiating
then the constraint
maybe this is right i don't know what no
no you can't do that you know if you did
if you did sort of say in that first
command there if you said y comma
constraint
then you still need to sort of say that
y is sort of a bound variable
so why
y with this doesn't work no no no you
have to keep the y
because that's a bound variable
basically
i don't understand this what so the
function that you want to differentiate
is y
right yes
okay y and x are related in a constraint
where y is a bound variable
yes
okay
and then there's x that you
differentiate
that's the independent variable but why
do i need to give the y
because it's it's a bound variable and
it can be many bound variables you can
have many y's and many x's
if you go down if you if you this is i'm
thinking about this for a second i'm
thinking about this because what you're
saying is
you could say in a partial derivative i
mean our d is a partial derivative
so i don't quite understand why
don't you immediately know
no there could be parameters too
why could it can be parameters too
it could be an a in there
okay
f of g
f g 0
y x so you're differentiating this with
this constraint
you're differentiating this quantity
with this constraint
i don't quite understand what is the
role of the y here it's the it says that
those are
dependent variables so y depends on x
if there are other symbols there in g
like an a or something that's a
parameter
okay
yeah i mean i understand structurally
what that means i just don't understand
i don't know we imagine a bead on us on
a on a wire or something and the
constraint gives
where the bead is
and this is going to be the acceleration
how do i compute the acceleration of the
bead
see what i'm saying and so the bead is
constrained to be on a wire
with right constraint here
and then i would be computing the
acceleration
which is the change of position
on the
so so in that so let's say the beat is a
line okay i'm sorry the wire is a line
let's just do the example so so it's
uh
so let me point out the thing that i'm
not easily getting there okay let's say
y equals x y double double equals x
sure but let me point out something i'm
not getting okay in the case of the bead
on the circular wire let's say
one of the things i might differentiate
is the arc length here this first
argument might conveniently be the arc
length right right
but i don't have an easy way to get that
do i how do i get the arc length
and the simplest implicit derivative
because normally i wouldn't care about
the arc line i mean you need to use the
function arc length then probably
to get the arc length if that's the
function you want
well okay but i mean so what you're
saying is if i if i want to get this
okay so let's do the explicit example
okay so i've got
the the i've got my bead on a circle
okay
okay now i want to compute the second
derivative
of the arc length here for the bead how
do i do it the the last argument you
have x comma two you know like we do
inside i i i i get that part i can do
that part
right but i just don't know i don't want
it i no no wait a minute i don't want x
to because what i want is the bead is
running around
the thing and i'm actually
differentiating
[Music]
the bead is moving at a certain speed
and these are its coordinates
okay
and so what do you want i'm actually
fairly confused so i'm there's the thing
needs to have an arc length the thing
that i want to find is the acceleration
with respect to arc length of the bead
i really want to re-parameterize it
basically with
with respect to arc length i think so i
think that's a common case for implicit
derivatives
um
[Music]
perhaps i'm confused but it seems like
that to me
i'm i'm i'm flagging that i don't quite
understand i mean by the time you're
doing implicit derivatives it seems to
me that you're doing things on curves
like this
yeah right but that's the point you're
doing things on curves and surfaces
right it means that the quantities that
you want to deal with will often be
things like arc length
or some curvature quantity on the
surface
not so much
the rectilinear x and y coordinates
um
but that requires a whole different
level of description if we're going to
get to that
does it i'm not sure it does
i mean some of these surfaces have
infinite
i mean they they can be unbounded they
sure if it's a line it's not bounded
it's
yeah no i understand i understand but
there's some notion
i'm i'm i'm telling you i'm i'm not
getting this quite properly right now
but i'm telling you there's a there's a
reason why we're going to care about
having symbolic wrapper that represents
arc length because this this
you know what we've got
here is we could represent this probably
by simply the the um you know the norm
of x y
here
i don't know whether that y is is that
right that y would just hang out like
that
that's particularly bad
well it's assuming
that was really bad at auto completion
that should be
oops
no i don't even know what the
that's
those are reals do can i just say that
no
you have to say
x-rays
and i said we could just do that
sploth
miners see though okay i i'm telling you
there's something about arc length
that's worth thinking about i don't know
exactly what it is
so i'm saying that but once you've got
an implicit curve here
you want to be
doing things with respect to the
implicit curve
okay cavi is commenting on a live stream
people might want the normal and tangent
derivatives tangent being with respect
to arc length but the representation is
much more complicated especially in
higher dimensions
okay that sounds like what i'm really
asking for is a tangential derivative of
some kind
so maybe that's not relevant to what
you're providing here
yeah
okay anyway i claim it it deserves some
thought
okay i made a note of that i'll check
with adam if we can do something over
there it is exemplified if it's possible
to i'm gonna have to run yeah i'm not
gonna have to run in a second here we
need one more round yeah we need a
second iteration of this let me just
look at integrate change variables and
then i'm gonna run you're gonna run
um
there's a lot of nice stuff here guys
well done
thank you
is this is this one version
or has this most of this stuff been
cooking for a while no we'd last four
months five months since november
basically
december probably yes but i think just
some of it leverages stuff okay yes
obviously we have layers and things that
have been
so implicit d for instance asymptotic
solve
you know is based on what implicit d
does that's what how you compute
asymptotic series
for instance
right
um
in in the in the non-singular cases
right i mean yeah i know i understand it
would be interesting one day to draw a
diagram of the power we've been building
for the past 35 years and what really
depended on what right midtech lefleur
was introduced
you know many years ago
we've improved it
uh we'll improve it some more
okay i need more time to understand this
i mean i'm not i i know you do
inactivated stuff here yeah yeah i know
i know
um
all right sounds good well thanks
everybody and thanks for the comments on
the live stream too actually we seem to
have one more comment here so let's see
what
one more comment before we help okay
thanks everybody